[موسيقى]
اهلا
فيك
اهلا وسهلا بك وشكرا
شكرا شكرا
بطبيعه
والحاجه الملحه للمساعده الانسانيه نحو
نصف السكان في اوكرانيا بحاجه للمساعده
الانسانيه اكثر من سبعه ملايين ملايين
خلال فتره قصيره وسته خمسه مليون
مرحب داخلي الظروف
بودر
بروبلم
[موسيقى]
والدفاع عنها
منذ 2014
شارع من الحروب
انصدمنا من عمليه الاعدام في السادس من
ديسمبر واتمنى ان العقلانيه ستعود الى
السلطات والتي نتمنى انها ستعلق عقوبه
الاعدام دوليه
ولد فلسفه اولا من الضروري
حقوق الانسان
الايرانيون حتى لو انهم قالوا انهم لن
يتعاونوا على كل نفس الشيء بالنسبه لسوريا
لا نستطيع الدخول سوريا
روح تم توقيع اتفاق طاري بين
المدنيين والعسكريين
يقضي بتشكيل حكومه من المدنيين حتى اجراء
الانتخابات بعد سنتين
التقيتم الزعماء العسكريين هل تعتقدون
فعلا بانها هؤلاء سيسهلون انتقال الحكم
الى المدنيين وهل تعتقدون بانهم سيحترمون
حقوق الانسان بشكل اكبر
حب السودان
[موسيقى]
رايت برابسي
2019 بفضادا
ينتظرون فعلا العداله
موضوع الانتقال السياسي مع التركيز طبعا
على انهم ضحايا لانهم فقدوا احبابهم ومره
اخرى اقول هذا جزء من العمليه الانتقاليه
المعقده واتمنى فعلا انها تتواصل الى
نتائج ايجابيه
في اخر يوم من ولاياتها يتحدث عن ثاني
حدوث جرائم ضد الانسانيه
التقرير سينتهي في
احد
الادراج في جنيفا ام انكم على استعداد
النقليه مناقشه هذا الموضوع مع سلطات
الصينيه
في 31 من اغسطس وهو يتطرق الى قضاياه
منحاس ولا تقبله
لوك انا اركز على التوصيات في تقرير نعم
بدانا
بنقاشها مع سلطات هذا هو واجبي ان متابعه
توصياتها في اماكن عديده من
العالمون هذه المهمه في هذا الوقت الحرج
جدا
لا تعتبر فيه
الحقوق الانسانيه في جواهر في الصين
في عام
القادحتفل بالذكرى ال 75 للاعلان العالمي
لحقوق الانسان
لميتين
فضيعتين والهلوكس
اخرى وتلك الوثيقه الجلابه الامل للشعوب
واظهرت محوريه حقوق الانسان
داخل كل بلد وفي العلاقات بين البلدان هذا
النص
يتسي اهميه اليوم كما كان يكتسي اهميه غدا
الحرب العالميه الثانيه على كل شيء ينبغي
على الجميع ان همم يلتزم بهذا الاعلان
منوع
شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
لقاء الابطال في قطر
اقوى لاعبي كره القدم في العالم يتنافسون
على الفوز بالكاس من 20 نوفمبر الى 18
ديسمبر
تابع نشره المونديال يوميا على فرانس 24